knowing what you know now what would you
say to your 22 year old self you have to
go for your actual dream the one that
scares you the most because it's the one
you want the most but you haven't even
thought you had a chance to do it that's
what 22 to 30 is about it's all high
risk you are in the most practical place
from 22 to 30 to do crazy ass [ __ ] you
don't need a lot of money to live you
can live with 40 of your [ __ ] friends
let alone three you could you can eat
like [ __ ] in your 20s so you can buy
dollar food you don't have kids but the
world has taught kids that that's the
time you're supposed to have it figured
out it's insane yes of course there are
a small group of professions that the
passion in the school and you know for
everybody else people understand how
life actually works like if you could
just get into the game weird things
happen it's working for free which comes
in all shapes and sizes like it's zero
if you're miraculously in that situation
or a shitty job that gives you plenty of
hours to be in the thing but the real
answer to your question is the dream
that you haven't even felt comfortable
believing in